Shorts we reviewed number three. We discussed the issue of mixing meat and fish. That we learned is a problem of sakana, is dangerous to mix meat and fish, to the extent that the Shulchan Aruch says that a person has to wash their hands and their mouth, wash out their mouth between eating meat and fish.
The Rama, on the other hand, says that a person is not required to wash their hands and mouth between meat and fish.
However, it is preferable to eat and drink something between meat and fish.
We brought in the opinion of the Magnavram, who says that nowadays the natures of people have changed and it is no longer dangerous to eat meat and fish together.
We did say that that is a tzirif, that is something that we will rely on in conjunction with other factors to be lenient,
but we do not rely on the Magnavram straight and we do not change our practice.
b'shishim,
The suggestion was to boil water in the pot and then spill it out, and that would permit using the pot right away.
In a situation where a person wants to serve meat and fish on the same table, that was a machokas between the poskim,
or Vosner, or Avadya, which said that it would be allowed because the danger of mixing them together is enough to keep people from doing so.
However, the Kaf HaChaim said that it's forbidden, but again, most poskim we saw said that it would be allowed.
The fact that it's a sakana that's dangerous would keep people from mixing them together, and it's not the same as meat and milk together.
We discuss Worcestershire sauce, which contains fish. We discuss the discussion whether or not it should be just a regular OU or an OU fish.
However, a person should know that if it is not baltabashishim, the OU does hold that they put the fish on the label.
But even in that situation, a person would be allowed to mix the sauce with more power of ingredients,
which will ultimately be mevato and nullify the amount of fish in the sauce to then use it with meat, even l'chachila.